hello and welcome to Khan Academy live
SAT I'm Eric I'm an SAT tutor and one of
the SAT experts here at Khan Academy and
I'm so excited to be with you today to
talk through SAT reading now if you
joined one of our past live streams will
notice that today's live stream looks a
little bit different and that's because
our amazing videographer Felipe is out
today but so that means we're using a
bit more of a homemade setup and so
you'll actually get to see me a
switching back and forth a little bit
between screens and so you get a peek
behind the scenes and hopefully there
will be any tech glitches but if there
are just going to bear with me and we'll
get those resolved so like I said
today's topic is SAT reading and so I'm
just going to give you a quick overview
of what we're going to cover today
before we get straight into the content
so time to share my screen here and so
for today today's class like I mentioned
the topic is SAT reading and we're going
to cover a lot of different topics here
and next week we will cover SAT writing
and it will be at the same time so
Tuesday at 7 p.m. Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific
it will be the third and final part of
our series and last week in case you
missed it we had an SAT math class and
so if you missed that don't worry just
head to our Khan Academy YouTube channel
and you can find the recording there but
like I mentioned today is all about SAT
reading and that's what we're here for
and so scroll through and you'll see the
schedule for today's class so the first
10 minutes of class I'm going to go
through two things the first is the
rephrase and predict strategy and this
is a proactive strategy that you can use
to tackle SAT reading questions the
second topic I'm going to cover is time
management and I'm going to walk through
some of the most common questions I get
when it comes to time management and
pacing yourself and not running out of
time on the SAT reading section next up
I'm going to work through a real SAT
reading passage together and then we'll
do some Q&A and wrap up at the very end
we'll answer some of your questions and
also share a Khan Academy badge
so I'll stop sharing then for now and so
that's what we have planned for the day
there's a lot to get into and so let's
jump straight into the first reading
strategy which is all about the rephrase
and predict strategy so share my screen
again and so the reason we're talking
about this strategy is for a few reasons
and so let's think through these
questions and let me know if any of
these sound familiar to you
so have you ever read the answer choices
in an SAT reading section and thought to
yourself well I love these look good and
it could be any of them or maybe you get
it down to two choices but then pick the
wrong one so maybe you've got it down to
a or C but then you sometimes take the
right one sometimes pick the wrong one
or maybe you run out of time in the
reading section and so these things of
all I've definitely experienced all of
these things myself and a lot of
students have been in this situation and
so that's why this rephrase in predict
strategy can really help address these
situations and so what is this strategy
well this strategy is all about coming
up with your own answer to reading
questions before you look at the answer
choices and this is really important and
the reason you want to hold off on
looking at the answer choices is that
one it's lots of information to take in
and two perhaps most importantly it can
be distracting and so it can sometimes
lead you and influence your
interpretation and understanding of the
passage before you have a good grasp and
so you know that I like to call this the
the rabbit hole effect here and you
don't want to be led down the wrong path
and so the two parts to this strategy
are one to rephrase and so this involves
reading the question but covering the
answer choices and then if possible
rephrase the question is well how what
or why question to simplify to simplify
and make it easier to understand the
next part in this strategy is to predict
and that is this involves reviewing the
relevant parts of the passage
and predicting the answer in your own
words and once you have this answer you
can then uncover the answer choices
cross out the choices that don't match
and then select the choice that best
matches and so this converts the SAT
reading question into more of a matching
question so if you already have
something in mind it allows you to put
these two things what you have in mind
and compare it with the answer choices
that you have in the on the SAT reading
test and once it's a matching exercise
most students find it easier and faster
as well so we'll get plenty of time to
practice this later today but for now
I'm going to move on to time management
and we're going to work through some of
the most common time management
questions that I get and so keep move
your gaze to the bottom of the screen
here and we'll walk through these
questions one at a time so the first
question is should you read the
questions or the passage first and if
you have an answer go ahead and type
that in and you know feel free to share
that with others who are watching the
live stream so should you read the
questions or the passage first well I
would recommend that well it actually
kind of is up to you so you want to do
what works for you but I would say that
scanning the questions can help focus
your attention as you read the passage
and say you have trouble running out of
time
on the reading passage it can be
particularly helpful because maybe you
realize you know I won't be able to read
through the whole passage I won't be
able to answer all the questions but
maybe I can hone in on the easier
questions and I do those and so I you
want to do what works for you but I
would encourage you to try scanning the
questions first to see how that feels
try reading the passage first and do
what works best okay next question
should you answer all reading questions
in order or can you jump around I want
to say this is within the passage so say
you have a passage and you have 11
questions
should you answer all reading questions
in order or
and jump around you can absolutely
jumper out so jump around to your
heart's content as long as you keep
track of the questions you've skipped
and so what that means is say you skip
number 17 and 18 you'll just want to
star these in your test booklets so that
you remember to go back and the reason
you want to jump around well we'll get
to that in just a second but it's
absolutely okay to jump around within
the SAT reading section within a passage
next up a next question should you do
the easy or harder reading questions
first
as you go through should you do the easy
or harder reading questions first so you
never want to do the easy questions
first and that's because all questions
are worth the same number of points so
it could be the hardest reading question
in the whole section it's worth at the
same amount as the easiest question on
the SAT
furthermore answering the easy questions
first can help with time management and
also help you better understand the
passage so maybe you've read the passage
in you're still here you've got some
question marks and you're not quite sure
you've understood
well these easier questions can help you
break down the passage into its
individual parts and then build your
understanding of the passage now what do
you know easy questions sometimes look
like what easy questions tend to be now
this isn't always the case but they tend
to be more specific and what I mean by
more specific is that they'll have a
line reference in them so line eight
indicates and so it'll tell you exactly
where in the passage you want to look
whereas the harder questions and this
you know again isn't a doesn't apply in
all cases but harder questions tend to
be broader and they might ask you to
compare and contrast and so those
questions tend to take a little bit
longer and so if I have a choice
I tend to leave those for later okay
so a few more time management questions
here
so should you jump between questions for
different passages jump between
questions for different passages so I'm
saying you have passage 1 and passage 2
is it okay to answer some questions in
passive one and then some questions in
passage two and kind of go back and
forth if you have a hunch go ahead and
type that into the comments there so my
recommendation is no I don't I would not
recommend jumping between passages and
you want to do your best answer all
questions related to a passage before
moving on and the reason for that is
that switching tends to take your brain
a decent amount of time so in this
process this process of switching back
and forth is time consuming and if you
sometimes have trouble finishing this
section you don't want to do anything
that's time-consuming and takes away
your time so this is different from what
I mentioned before so within the passage
within a passage it's okay to jump
within passage is is okay to jump okay
to jump wait now final question here if
you're running out of time should you
always guess if you're running out of
time should you always guess answer is
yes you should absolutely always guess
because there is no guessing penalty so
even if you have five or ten or however
many questions left always go to your
answer sheet and bubble in a your best
guess especially if you know you have a
minute left or thirty seconds left it's
always better to guess so you have a
chance that at earning that last point
now we'll do a quick review of these
time management questions but you have
any questions go ahead and type those in
the comments as I'll be answering a few
time management questions shortly so if
you have questions go ahead and submit
them and I'll get to those in a second
so should you read the questions or the
passage first again this is do what
works for you but scanning the questions
can help should you answer all reading
questions in order or can you jump
around you should
solutely feel free to jump around within
a passage should you do the easier
harder questions first you should
definitely do the easy questions and try
starting there it can really help can
you jump between questions of different
passages no should you always guess yes
and so that is uh those are some of the
most common time management questions I
get and for now I'm going to answer a
few time management questions that you
all have and so I'm going to flip back
here to stop screen sharing that's the
screen ception there so if you have
other time management questions go ahead
and type them into the comments and all
work through a few of them before moving
on to a real SAT reading passage so
let's take a look um should you skip
certain questions altogether now that's
an interesting question um I'd say I
would encourage you to scan through all
of the questions relating to a passage
and then if you're running particularly
low on time and one question um you know
just looks like it's going to take a
solid three four minutes then in that
case it's completely fine to say okay
I'm making a decision I'm going to skip
number 18 and just make sure like I
mentioned to note that you skip that
question so that on your answer sheet
when you're bubbling things in you don't
accidentally miss bubbles so that's
probably the most important thing you
want to remember when you are skipping
questions is that you want to mark down
in your answer sheet where you skip
these questions so you don't miss bubble
anything but you know if you if you're
running low on time and you see a
question that's going to be really tough
and time-consuming it's okay to skip it
um let's see Jim or fully so is it
better to skim or fully read the passage
so that's a great another great question
and I would say that you'll want to
practice that and try a few were a few
try a few approaches yourself so I like
to read the whole passage and you know
be pretty active as I go along to mark
down you know what this paragraph is
saying what the author's next point is
but for some people they'll what they
can do is skim through the passage and
look through whether they're called the
topic sentences and that's the first
sentence in each paragraph and that can
be a quicker way of gaining some
understanding but I'd say you know
skimming the passage and hoping to get a
large number of the questions right is
going to be difficult at some point you
will need to really understand what the
author's is saying and their position on
on the topic let's see what do you do if
you don't understand a passage so there
I would again go back to there a few
things I'd recommend one would be to
read just the topic sentence of each
paragraph to get a broad understanding
without getting too detailed another
approach that I mentioned is to tackle
some of the easier questions first and
those easy questions will be more
specific to just certain parts of the
passage and if you can digest that
smaller part of the passage you can
often build up your understanding so
that you understand the author's main
points and the broader passage itself so
we'll have more time to answer these
questions later
but for now I want to take some time to
work through some real ICT reading
questions but like I mentioned as I'm
working through these questions if you
have there's something confusing or you
want me to answer a question that you
have to type in those questions along in
the chat we'll be collecting those
questions all throughout and we'll do
I'll do some more Q&A at the very end
for now though we're going to do a real
SAT reading section and get to as many
of those questions as we can so you can
see what these strategies look like
within the context of a real passage so
let's dive in share my screen again
share okay so like I mentioned I like to
take a look at some of the questions
first and just give a quick scan and
I've changed the format here just to
make it easier for you to read but so
let's take a scan through these
questions what main affect you the
phrase paradigm shift and tilt that
equation have on the meaning of the
passage so that's a
trysting we've got lying 8 here in line
48 and 49 actually bring this back in
here so paradigm shift line 8 tilt that
equation so this one is specific but it
also has two parts of the passage that I
need to look at so it might take a
little bit of time based on the passage
what is the significance of Jeffrey
batas experiment so bad is a name I want
to pay attention to according the
passage the main problem with the
miller-urey experiment so another name I
want to pay attention to and then I've
got two pretty specific ones here line
29 in line 44 about more vocabulary
words in context then we've got main
objections of Audis conclusion and then
which twice provides the best evidence
so here I'm just from scanning these
questions I honed in on a few important
parts of the passage that I want to look
at so line a line 48 I have some names
that I want to pay attention to so bata
miller-urey and then from this question
I've picked up that there's some back
and forth here so um there's some back
and forth here but sounds like between
scientists so we're talking about
conclusions and experiments and so I
want to look at the the kind of
arguments that are being made here and
so this is my quick scan of questions
and now what I'll do is flip over to the
passage itself and do some active
reading and don't worry we'll go back to
the questions in a second but hopefully
you can see this clearly and what I mean
by active reading is that I will be
underlining and boxing and making
comments and checks and happy faces and
smiley faces along the way to help me
understand as I'm going through and so
I'll start with the blurb here and so
that's this is the blurb so this passage
is x-rated from Douglas Fox primordial
soups on scientists repeat evolutions
most famous experiments by scientific
American's so again it's a science
passage let's take a weed a freakin
stylus contraption of glass bowl
herbs and crackling electrodes has
produced yet another revelation about
the origin of life okay so that's my
introduction we're talking about the
origin of life and the results suggest
that Earth's early atmosphere could have
produced chemicals necessary for life
contradicting the view that
contradicting the view that life's
building blocks had to come from comets
and meteors so this is what's called a
topic sentence in the paragraph and so
it tells me a lot about what is going to
be ahead and the paragraph in what I've
gleaned from this is that Earth might
have had the chemicals necessary for
life and we have a but word here so
contradicting the view that life
building blocks had to come from
comments and so that's important I like
to circle these contrasting kind of hold
on but not yet worked so maybe we're
over optimistic but I think this is a
paradigm shift okay so that was that
line eight word there and says chemists
Jeffrey bada whose team performed the
experiment at the Scripps Institute of
Oceanography and La Jolla California on
Baba was revisiting the famous
experiment first done by his mentor
chemist Stanley Miller
okay so Miller that was a name that I
wanted to pay attention to so I've got
Miller and Urey used a sparking device
to mimic a lightning storm the
experiment produced a brown broth rich
in amino acids the building blocks of
proteins Disclosure made the pages of
national magazines so make the pages of
national magazines and showed that
theories about the origin of life be
tested in a laboratory so this seems to
be like a big positive outcome some add
some pluses here and produce brown broth
rich in amino acids I've got some you
know acids that are here okay great
so let's continue reading here here's
another one of those contrasting words
so but anytime that comes up it's
usually worth paying attention to the
Miller area results were later
questioned it turns out that the gases
he used a reactive mixture of methane
and ammonia did not exist in large
amounts on early Earth scientists now
believe the primeval atmosphere
contained in
a mix of carbon dioxide and nitrogen a
change that made a world of difference
okay so just to recap here in the
passage we have experiment by bata up
here so this is bata and then we have
Miller here and so initially we're
feeling pretty happy but then now we're
feeling sad um so change made a world of
difference I'm gonna well I don't know
that it's sad yet but I'll just there's
definitely a kind of shift happening
here
so when Miller repeated the experiment
using the correct combo in 1983 the
broth failed to materialise instead it
created a colorless through containing
few amino acids it seemed to refute a
long-cherished icon of evolution and
creationists quickly seized on it as
supposed evidence of evolutions wobbly
foundations so seized was another one of
those words that we were asked about in
the questions so I want to start this
there and so like I mentioned it seemed
seems like the experiment did not go as
well the second time around
and then we have yet another but so but
another shift that's happening you
bought is repeated the experiment armed
with new insight seems likely to turn
the tables once again bata discovered
that the reactions were producing
chemicals called nitrites which destroy
amino acids as quickly as they form they
were also turning the water acidic which
prevents amino acids from forming yet
primitive earth would have contained
iron and carbonate minerals that
neutralized nitrites and acids so bata
added the chemicals to the experiment to
duplicate these functions when he reread
it he's still got the same watery liquid
but this time chock full of amino acid
so this amino acids keeps coming up and
so I'm gonna mark out that this time he
did have it and so now we've shifted
back to Bottas point of view here and I
just want to note that this had no amino
acids here I'm just fine know that okay
I'll read a little bit more so it's
important work Christopher McKay
planetary scientist at NASA Ames
Research
Center this move toward more realism in
terms of what conditions were on early
Earth I'm so important work so this is
positive most researchers believe that
the origin of life depended heavily on
chemicals delivered to Earth by comets
and meteorites but if the new work holds
up it could tilt that equation so that
is another one of the questions that we
were asked is astrobiologists at
Princeton that would be a terrific
result for understanding the origin of
life and for understanding the prospects
for life elsewhere okay and a little bit
more but another but lots of buts
James Ferris a prebiotic chemist at
Rensselaer Polytechnic doubts that
atmospheric electricity so not yet
there's a bit of a hold on tone here
could have been the only source of
organic molecules you get a fair amount
of amino acids what you don't get are
things like the building blocks of
nucleic acids meteors comments or
primordial ponds would still need to
provide these molecules sivadas
experiment could have implications for
life on Mars because the red planet may
have been swaddled in nitrogen and
carbon dioxide early in its life bob
intends to test this extrapolation by
doing experiments with lower pressure
mixes those guesses
okay so that was a lot of information
but as you as i zoom out don't worry
about trying to read it right now I just
want you to look at how many underlining
how much I've underlined how much I've
boxed and how much I've annotated this
passage and that it takes some time but
as you practice more and more you'll get
faster up reading while annotating and
what this annotation does is make it
easier for you to find the relevant
information once you go through the
questions so now I've done that and now
I'm going to show bring up the actual
questions and we're going to step
through these one by one so I'm zooming
in making sure you can read it here so
what main effect do the phrases paradigm
shift line eight until that equation
have on the meaning of the passage so
paradigm shift and line eight
change colors here paradigm shift in
line eight and so let's take a read here
before we jump to lines 48 to 49
so you'll notice I haven't looked at any
of these answer choices I've gone
straight from the question to the
passage and that this is all about
coming up with your own answer before
you look at the answer choices so let's
see let's read some of the context along
here so maybe we're over optimistic but
I think this is a paradigm shift I'm
contradicting the views a paradigm shift
shift usually means that there's a
change going on so it sounds like
there's a change and our thinking and
then likes 48 to 49 tilts that equation
lines 48 to 49 here so here I've starred
this and so most researchers believe the
origin of life depended on chemicals but
if the new work holds up it could tilt
that equation and that would be a
terrific result for understanding the
origin of life and for understanding
prospects so tilt that so if the new
work holds up it could tilt that
equation and so we're talking about
beliefs here and so this again is
reinforcing this fact that there's a
change in beliefs that's happening and
so my that's going to be my prediction
for question number one Oh what's the
main effect that these words have on the
meaning of the passage and so the main
effect I'm saying is that it change it
indicates a change in the leaf that's
happening and so now I want to match
this against these answer choices here
so I a they imply that the accepted
theory is regarding the origin of life
on earth are groundless
so groundless that seems pretty strong
and it doesn't match my prediction that
it's these phrases just indicate that
there's going to change in the belief in
what scientists believe they indicate
that Miller's experiment regarding the
origin of life on Earth has sparked a
debate so I like this word debate
I'll leave a question mark here and I'll
leave that in contention they suggest a
shift in scientific thought regarding
the origin of life on Earth so that
shift and scientific thought regarding
the origin of life on Earth so this is
pretty darn close to a change that I
have in mind and so we've got a change
there and so I like that and then so
that one is you know in the lead right
now and then D they signal that
scientists are now certain how life
began on earth so scientists are not
certain where there's still a lot of
experiments and it seems like things are
going in a promising direction but we
are not certain and so with that process
of elimination and matching I know that
my answer is going to be C rating so
that was a early example of how you can
use the rephrase and predict strategy to
come up with your prediction here and
then match it with the answer choices
and it's usually easier to match I once
you have a belief a prediction in your
mind than to go in and hope that of one
of these will fit so for now I'm going
to do some quick erasing just to make it
easier later but that was answer choice
C so bear with me these are some of the
tech things that I mentioned earlier
okay so now I want to look at question
number two - based on the passage so I'm
in a little more the significance of
Geoffrey bada's experiment risk mainly
on his success at so the significance of
Geoffrey blattis experiment risk mainly
on his success at okay so now I want to
go back to the passage again and look at
the relevant parts that relate to data
and his success and so we have data here
and we've got batter here and so I'm
almost using my notes as a map so I can
jump directly to where is what the
relevant parts are in the passage and so
let's take a look we've got data um so
results suggest that
Chemical Earth's early atmosphere could
have produced chemicals necessary for
life we think this is a paradigm shift
and so this is creating life okay so
that's some context there and then I've
also got more about information from
bada here so bad I discovered that the
reactions are producing nitrites you
have primitive earth would have
contained carbonate okay so I'm just
scanning now so but I added chemicals
and when he reran it got the same water
liquid but is chock full of amino acids
and so this is a success right so he
kind of proved that amino acids came in
and so that is successful and so based
on this reread of the passage the
significance is really bad he was
successful in reproducing the amino
acids and so that in an experimental
setting and so so the significance is
that he had successfully um successfully
produced amino acids form spec success
with amino acids with amino acids so now
let's see which one of these matches
here so confirming that the production
of amino acids on early Earth was
possible so that is amino acids was
possible so that is pretty quote a
pretty close match explaining the
critical function of my tracks to the
production of amino acids so that did
support the production and the
experiments so that is a maybe in my
book neuro fiying the presence of
nitrites in Earth's atmosphere as well
as in comets and meteors so he didn't
mention these comets and meteors when he
reran the experiment and so it's not
that he verified that they were in them
so that is he'll then tracing the
development of different types of amino
acids on earth so not only have we not
talked about different types of amino
acids but again my prediction is that he
was the significance comes from the fact
that he successfully created these amino
and so that is most like answer choice a
right so now question number three
according to the passage the main
problem with the miller-urey experiment
was that so the main problem with the
Miller array experiment so now I want to
go through here and look through the
Miller array experiment and look here
I've got Miller and then I've got more
Miller here so I want to reread this and
I'm looking for the problem from myth in
the Miller array experiment and I've got
this buck here and at this sad face so I
want to hone in on this sad face here
because it's probably where I need to
pay attention so but the Miller area
results for later question it turns out
that the gases he used did not exist in
large amounts scientists now believe
that the new atmosphere contained a mix
of carbon dioxide and nitrogen the
change made a world of difference and
then when he reran it the broth failed
to materialise and so didn't work
anymore and so it sounds like these
results were later questioned because
the gases he used were kind of incorrect
given at this new belief and so if I go
back down here to the questions the main
problem was that he you know there was a
new belief and new understanding about
the gases about gases and then that
meant that when he used this new system
then amino acids did not show up so
let's take a read here at number three
according to the passage to these answer
choices the results have never been
duplicated in subsequent scientific
experiments so the issue is not that
they've never been duplicated and my
prediction was that there was a new
belief that made amino acids invalid and
that original setup didn't work anymore
so it's not about duplication the
discovery of new evidence and validated
the method of analysis so new evidence
is pretty much syncs with new
if there is similar to belief and so
invalidated the method of analysis and
so yep it meant that his original
experiment didn't work so that it's
pretty close and then the conclusion
neglected to account for the ambiguous
nature of the results on neglected to
account for the ambiguous nature of the
results nope I'm again it's not matching
my prediction around the new belief and
so I can toss that out there then the
research you methods used in the study
we're ineffective in a laboratory
setting so this one also feels closed
the research methods used in the study
were ineffective in the laboratory
setting and so now we are at that
age-old crossroads of having to answer
choices left B or D so which one do we
think it is so maybe you suggested a few
things in the passage are in the image
chat but what I like to do is go back to
the passage and look at the evidence
because the correct answer when it comes
down to 50 50 50 things like this will
always be supported by more evidence in
the passage so the main problem with the
Miller array experiment and that's going
to be up here so the results were later
questioned and there was this new belief
and a change made a world of difference
and so rerunning it meant that he no
longer got the results he wanted and so
to me the new belief is really what
makes it for me
and there's more evidence to support
this in the passage so the discovery of
new evidence invalidated his original
experiment that you see up here and so
answer is going to be B and because we
just did that which choice best supports
the answer to the previous question
which choice best supports the answer to
the previous question will we just
looked at that up here and so this is
really where we want to pay attention it
turns out that the gases he used did not
exist and scientists now believe
so let's see which part which answer
choice matches that it turns out and go
so there's our answer
and that was exactly the text we use so
it turns out that the gas is he used did
not exist in large amounts in early
Earth so I'll do one more question um
and let's take a look here let's see
questions 5 through 8 I'll move this
passage over and look at that magic um
ok and so questions 5 through 8 let's
take a look here as used in line twenty
nine seized on most nearly means so
seized on line 29 and it seemed to
refute the long term style kind of
evolution and creationist quickly seized
on seized on it I'll swim in here so
Miller we ran the experiment the broth
failed to materialise we have no amino
acids and creation has quickly seized on
it as supposed evidence of evolutions
wobbly foundations so it sounds like
creationists were pretty happy about the
experiments failure and so it sounds
like they're they're almost bragging
about the fact that the experiment
failed and so that's my prediction for
this word and so what we've got is
bragging and so which one of these words
bragging about the evidence matches this
prediction of not bragging about the
evidence so they embraced the evidence
that is not the same connotation or
meaning as bragging took advantage of
the evidence that was pretty close so
we'll leave that in they caught the
evidence so that it's not the same as
bragging about it they grappled with the
evidence so this almost means
grappling is almost the same as
discussing the evidence or wrestling
with it to see you know if it's valid
but they didn't really discuss a wrestle
with it it was more just about bragging
kind of saying aha I've got you and so
answer choices going to be e so that was
a run-through of the practice reading
strategies and time management
strategies within the context of a real
SAT reading passage now as I went
through it I you know took my time
explain my thinking a lot more and so
you know spent a little bit longer per
question if you're doing this by
yourself you would as you gain more
practice doing this get faster and
faster at this but you know want to call
that some of y'all are probably saying
huh if you spent a lot of time for a
question you know it's just for the
purpose of illustrating how to use this
strategy but as you practice at home by
yourself with it with a stopwatch with
the timer you'll really get faster and
you'll be able to move more quickly
through this so now I'm going to do a
walk through how you'll get your badge
and then I'll answer some final
questions so to get your badge
look at the YouTube chat next to the
live stream and there will be a link to
the badge once you click the badge
you'll be able to you'll be asked to log
into your Khan Academy account and then
in the top right corner is where you're
going to get a notification that says
hey you've got your bed and so click the
link log in get your badge now finally
I'm going to do some more questions and
answers and so if you have a question
about anything that I've covered go
ahead and type that in and I'll answer
as many as I can in the next few minutes
so let's take a look how much time
should you spend on a passage lots of
questions around this so in this in this
case I would say a few things so within
the reading section there are a handful
of passages and not only what I would
encourage you to do first is actually
look through the passages and say there
and and focus on the one that maybe
looks the easiest and prioritize the
easier ones over the hard ones and so
that'll let you one just focus your time
on the passages that you know look the
easiest
most understandable but then I would
just do the math and so you you'll know
that a reading section I think is I
don't want to misquote this but so look
at how much total time there is per in
the total reading section divided by the
total number of reading questions since
there are 11 questions per passage that
should help you get an idea of how much
time to spend on each individual one and
so just do the division and that would
be a good goal to aim for let's see how
do you improve your reading speed so
another good question and sadly there's
not a silver bullet to this other than
practicing and reading a lot so it's not
that you have to read a million SAT
reading passages but the work that
you're doing in your English class and
you know if you're reading a novel or
reading nonfiction we'll all speed up
your reading speed here the only thing I
might suggest within the SAT context is
if you are running low on time to scan
those topic sentences at the start of
each paragraph as that can give you a
good overview of the passage without
needing to read every single word let's
see okay for those questions asking a
point and make that and then making you
find the evidence do you read the
evidence first or or figure out the
answer first
so I would strongly encourage that you
figure out the answer first and what
that does is that you what that will
force you to do is to go back into the
passage to the parts that are relevant
for the question evaluate the evidence
yourself first and then as you come up
with your prediction for the right
answer you naturally make the connection
and you'll say in your head well I think
it's you know the author's point is this
because of this line right here and the
power comes from when you can say it's
because of this line right here and when
you combine those you have not only the
answer to the first question
but because part as you're saying it in
your head is the evidence and the answer
to that second part of the question
let's see how do you practice reading
comprehension so I would say there
are the practice sections within
official SAT practice on Khan Academy
are a great way to do it and so as you
practice those sections have 11
questions each very similar to what
you'll see on the SAT the real SAT
reading section and I would just you
know have a timer there so that you're
simulating the time pressure of that
you'll actually experience and work
through it at a good speed and try and
make sure you're doing it within the
time frame do you need to annotate how
can you annotate that much in the
limited time and can you write in the
test book so I would say annotate as
much as you can without really slowing
yourself down too much it's it's a bit
of a compromise that you're striking so
if you read really fast
you might not you might be going too
fast
so that it's actually you you may not
have understood everything by annotating
you slow down and check for
understanding at each place but I do
understand that the first few times
you're annotating it might take a little
bit more time so as you practice you'll
get faster and you'll get faster at
reading understanding and annotating all
at once and your final question can you
write on the test booklet absolutely so
mark that mark that test booklet up as
much as you want and the more you mark
it up the more hands-on you are the
better let's see how do you best go
about answering paired passages so great
questions so paired passages are and
really interesting beasts and the way I
would do that is you have two passages
right passage a and passage B what you
want to do is answer pack read passage a
answer passage a questions read passage
B answer passage B questions and then
those questions that ask you to compare
and contrast passage a and B those
obviously require the most understanding
across both passages and you want to
save those for the end and so this goes
back to that time management tip that I
shared earlier that says you know stay
within a passage do all the questions
related to that first passage before you
shift to the second passage and then
finally those hardest flush the hardest
questions that cover everything you want
to save for the
and and so I'll just do one more
question and then we'll wrap things up
ah
[Music]
wait we have one what is the next
livestream that's from a good one to end
on so the next livestream is next
Tuesday same time so 7 p.m. Eastern 4
p.m. Pacific and we're going to cover
SAT writing and so that's all going to
be all about grammar and kind of how
important context is within an SAT
writing and language passage and so
that'll be next Tuesday same exact time
you can't make it don't worry we'll send
out the recording but that's all we have
all I have for you today and hopefully
you found this helpful and feel free to
go back and watch any of this if you
want to slow down and see a repeat but
hope you found this helpful and hope to
see you next Tuesday at the same time
take care